Tony thanks for joining us how you
feeling today doing well dp2 really
different games but they were they were
fun to watch and this is just a great
time of year in the NFL when you do sit
as Doug Marrone said it comes down to it
boys your player to away from the Super
Bowl everything is so critical that it's
just awesome to watch would you rather
lose like Jacksonville did or Minnesota
did did you feel like hey we're closed
we just got to get back to work and go
to the next year a loss like Minnesota I
never saw that coming I thought
Philadelphia win but I thought it'd be
tight low scoring right down to the wire
and I know the Vikings had to be
disappointed that they just weren't able
to stop full Adelphia what did you
expect last night in Philadelphia I
thought it would be a 16-13 type of game
and the quarterback who made the fewest
mistakes would win I never expected
Philadelphia had a great game plan I
thought Nick Foles used the snap count
well to find out where the Minnesota
blitzes were coming from they used the
quick play-action got the ball out of
his hands fast they took some shots with
some big plays they did offensively they
had a very very good plan I did not see
them putting up you know 20-plus points
on the Vikings have a great defense and
they shredded them yeah and then you
start to look at that Minnesota or
Philadelphia offensively and defensively
those two lines I would think we would
be in agreement are better than the
Patriots all things have been defensive
once would you say that's right yes and
and that's what I couldn't understand
everybody kind of hit the panic button
when Nick Foles when the whole you know
the Eagles have no chance well they've
got a good football team they've got
four backs who can all do some things
they can run the ball they protect the
passer well they roll eight or nine
defensive linemen in there they get
after the capacitor they're difficult to
run against they're playing with with a
sense of community I just thought they
were going to be fine and Nick Foles
wasn't going to go in there and just you
know act like he had never played before
so I thought they had a legitimate
like and then you have Jacksonville
where it felt like Blake bortles had
confidence that they he made some throws
you got four net running the football
the defense looked pretty fresh and they
were they they were forcing New England
into their deep into their playbook but
you know what this feeling is like when
the Patriots know that you know that
they're going to win what is that like
when you just you know you start to
realize they're going to beat you well
the Patriots don't beat themselves and
that's the thing you have to go in there
and you have to play well and you have
to go win the game and I thought
Jacksonville took that approach in the
first half they made one mistake the
biggest mistake was the delay a game
after the time right right at the
two-minute warning they had a chance to
go into the locker room up 17 3 and had
the ball well they made that mistake and
the game got tight again once the game
was closed and a one score game
I thought Jacksonville in the second
half just running the ball on first down
constantly into that loaded defensive
front you know that that has been what
they've done they'd run for net but in
the first half the play-action pass is
on first down getting some easy throws I
thought they needed to continue that and
try to score again in the third quarter
in the fourth quarter and they just they
thought their defense could hold on but
you are only going to contain Brady for
so long yeah I don't know if we just
stopped ranking how great his
appearances his performances are because
when somebody says was that a great
performance by Brady yesterday doesn't
have Gronk for the second half they
already don't have Edelman in there and
I go I I don't know it just feels like
it's Brady being Brady you know that the
performance is the Falcons is one thing
I mean that's legendary historical
yesterday just felt like even with
stitches in his hand it just sort of
Brady being Brady it was and you just
know even when he was off a little bit
and they're having to settle for field
goals you give him too many chances he's
gonna score and the last couple of
drives just totally under control and
executing you know not something
fantastic but doing exactly what needed
to be done and that's their their
calling
card and that's what they do and so
defeat them you've got to have the same
level of performance for 60 minutes and
you know Atlanta saw that last year
Jacksonville saw it yesterday you you
cannot say hey we've got this game won
with three minutes to go and go into a
Cell you've got it you've got to win the
game he's Tony Dungy NBC football night
in America joining us Continental Tire
Coach's Corner
you know much is made of Belichick
taking away what you do best
how does Philadelphia use that same game
plan and take away what the Patriots do
best well it's gonna be hard for them to
do they're gonna have to take away the
middle of the field and I see New
England's the Rowan's 55 to 60 passes
again and worked in that middle of this
field I'm assuming Gronk will be back
but those those backs and tight ends are
going to be tough to cover so if silly
says okay we're gonna load up the middle
keep the safeties inside and just force
them to throw the ball outside to cooks
and see if you know if our corners can
hold up I think that strategy they're
going to take Minnesota had that
opportunity they could throw outside the
digs and did it often they just couldn't
do it consistently enough and can that
pass rush of Philadelphia affect some of
those outside throws that to me is gonna
be what determines the game on the other
side of the coin dollar check is going
to come up with a defensive philosophy
he and Matt Patricia how can we handle
this quick pass and quick play-action
pass game and also Philly especially
when a jolly plays in Clement plays
they've got a chance to get the ball
outside with their backs that's where
Jacksonville hurt the New England
defense young today with some of the
outside runs and silly has a better
handle on doing that so how is Belichick
going to come up with a plan to stop the
outside running and that quick short
passing game is Brady playing the
quarterbacking position better than
anybody has ever played
well he's yes and I don't think he's
playing it as well as he played it five
years ago I mean that that's when and
you can see subtle differences but he is
he's played at a high level for 15 17
years
that's the amazing part of it well
what's different than five years ago
he's a little bit not quite as accurate
not quite as precise but the big throws
when they need it he's still able to
make them with it when they were really
rolling with moss and welker he was
playing a level that that we hadn't seen
and they had more weapon other than
Gronkowski they don't have the weaponry
like they had back in those 708 in that
era but he's playing fantastic football
all see you in a week ring yeah looking
forward to it I won't be on the show out
there see what kind of sets you have out
at the Mall of America yeah and then we
have to we have to do the Super Bowl to
do we are we don't yeah yeah we're I
hope you blocked out like you know seven
hours there we got we got that prize
right now getting some some stuff for
the game and start to talk to their
players today and tomorrow so it should
be a lot of fun
Thank You coach safe travels I'll see
you in Minneapolis that's Tony Dungy
canal entire coaches corner from Sunday
rain to snow and everything in between
Continental Tire is engineered to tire
for what you do extraordinary
performance and reliability but in
confidence into driving for more
information and a location of a dealer
near you visit Continental Tire calm
come on Turner for what you do for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]